[Music]
coming up next it's book notes and this
week we bring you a discussion on the
ties between us and israeli intelligence
our guests are authors andrew and leslie
coburn and their book is titled
dangerous liaison the inside story of
the u.s israeli covert relationship
the coburns trace the association
between the u.s central intelligence
agency and the israeli intelligence
network from the founding of the state
of israel four decades ago through the
recent war in the middle east
[Music]
andrew coburn co-author of the book
dangerous liaison the inside story of
the u.s israeli covert relationship
what's the premise of your book
the premise is that
there's a side to the relationship
between the us and israel which goes
much beyond just the sort of sentimental
links and the links forged by supporters
of israel in this country
what we say what we explain is that
there has been since the almost the
earliest days of the israeli state and
these earliest days of the cia a secret
bond a secret
[Music]
andrew coburn co-author of the book
dangerous liaison the inside story of
the u.s israeli covert relationship
what's the premise of your book
the premise is that there's a side to
the relationship between the u.s and
israel which goes much beyond just the
sort of sentimental links and the links
forged by supporters of israel in this
country
what we say what we explain is that
there has been since the almost the
earliest days of the israeli state and
these earliest days of the cia a secret
bond a secret link between them
basically by which the israelis israeli
intelligence did jobs for the cia and
for the rest of american intelligence
and this you cannot understand what's
been going on around the world with
american covert operations and indeed
israeli covert operations until you
understand that the two countries have
this secret arrangement
leslie coburn what was the most
interesting
part of writing this book
well i mean
there are a number of things um
for example
uh one particular part which i found
most interesting was we talk about
israeli operations in colombia
and
some of the israeli commandos who
trained the hit squads of the medellin
cartel
it turns out that they had trained us in
israel as well
and when they were between trips to
colombia
these were the same people who also
trained most of the top commanders in
the guatemalan military
also trained the contras
and they were working they had a firm
that was under license to the israeli
ministry of defense
and then they turn up in the jungles of
puerto boyaca in colombia
so i mean we had a lot of adventures i
must say
did the israelis cooperate with you at
all in this book
well we talked to um you know we never
made an official approach to the israeli
government or mossad or anything like
that but we managed to get in the end to
talk to all the people we wanted to talk
to in israel uh we talked to people like
that for instance david kimchi
who was
had a long massage career he eventually
rose to be deputy head of mossad the
israeli secret
intelligence agency the equivalent of
the cia
and i remember a wonderful evening we
had in his home in his study
where he was talking in guarded fashion
about his career and intelligence he
then went on to be uh
director general of that foreign
ministry but
i suddenly noticed uh
around the walls of his study where we
were sitting it was like a history of
israeli covert operations because for
instance on one wall the most beautiful
wood carvings african wood sculptures
and they said oh they're lovely david
where'd you get those oh present from
abutu
yeah that one's nice where'd that come
from uh
picasso a central african empire then
another walls beautiful persian
miniatures uh where they come from oh
present from the shah for something we
did for him so uh
you know just there was this man sitting
this master spook
um surrounded by mementos of his career
and so we you know we talked to him we
spent a lot of time talking
as well there's a street
in tel aviv an avenue called shaol
hamalek which is
right across the street from what's
called the kiria which is the ministry
of defense compound it's a huge area in
the middle of tel aviv
and on the other side of charles
hameleck are a row of very fancy
high-rises
which is basically the headquarters of
these israeli military-industrial
complex i mean that area is so you have
offices of all the major arms dealers
the offices of the
israeli representatives of the major
american defense corporations you have
mossad headquarters just down one side
street you have a very beautiful
building
which is the headquarters of a man
called shaol eisenberg which not many
people
in the outside world know about but he's
certainly the richest and probably the
most powerful man in israel he's the
master arms dealer
uh behind a lot of political campaigns
behind a lot of politicians
again very much involved in this secret
world of arms deals and covert
operations that we talk about as the
link with america there were two
american names early in the book al
schwimmer
and hank greenspun
uh well al schwimmer um is again a
fascinating character um he
write at the very
birth of israel
um his real name is adolf schwimmer but
everyone calls him al
he was basically an arm smuggler for
israel he was flying in arms during
their war of independence um
from all over the place uh he was
originally a twa flight engineer in fact
but also a brilliant pilot
so for example he was flying arms from
uh prague because uh in the early days
of israel in fact
most of their arms or one of them their
most important single arm supplier was
the communist government in
czechoslovakia and schwimmer was part of
that he went on to found
israel aircraft industries in the
meantime still sort of flying arms you
know doing covert arms deals around the
world
and then years later
his energy is still undiminished he was
right at the heart of the iran contra
business he was you know absolutely
central at one point to the uh covert
shipments of arms to iran
hank greenspun was another fascinating
guy he um
he
was he was a u.s army veteran the end of
world war ii
and he was he just moved to las vegas to
set up a radio station when al schwimmer
suddenly knocked on the door he didn't
know him introduced by me to a friend
said hey drop everything i want you to
come with us and we're going to we're
going down to mexico we've got we need
you
to to go and vet some arms that we've
gotten hold of that we're buying
illegally in fact we need to get to
palestine for the strike so
so greenspan says oh okay drops
everything and get becomes an arm
smuggler briefly um
he disappears from his house for six
months comes back can't tell his wife or
he's been and he's you know been in
mexico bribing officials and
and um then he goes back to las vegas he
later became very famous as the
publisher of the las vegas son early
opponent of joe mccarthy fought howard
hughes
and was also actually interesting enough
he was the conduit for many years until
the campaign finance laws got tightened
up um
if uh candidates especially democratic
candidates who needed cash in a hurry
hank greenspan in las vegas was the man
to see because in las vegas of course a
lot of cash around
and if you in dire straits uh for
instance jimmy carter was
saved at a crucial moment of his
candidacy in 1976
um during the pennsylvania primary when
hank greenspan came up with sixty
thousand dollars so we have characters
go all the way through yeah i mean one
point about doing this kind of story
about covert operations with us and
israel is that because israel is such a
young country some of these people who
were there at the very beginning who
were making the deals in the 50s are
still alive we went to see uh isa harel
who was um
really a you know a
towering figure in covered operations uh
he was chief of mossad at a crucial time
in the 50s when the relationship that
this secret relationship we're talking
about was just getting going um this is
a you know there was a deal made in 1951
ben gurion came to washington and
offered the cia the services of israeli
intelligence who is ben gurion
ben gurion is the father of israel
he was prime minister for many years he
really steered the state to independence
uh students his people to independence
uh wrote the israeli declaration of
inter independence was prime minister
all the way through with a brief
interval
until 1963
i mean the israel you see today is
really the creation of david ben-gurion
originally from what country he was
originally from uh well from what's now
poland but was then russia part of i
mean it's the
territory that's changed hands um let me
go back to leslie coburn and ask her who
your favorite character was in your book
favorite character um most interesting
person
well let's see
that's it's a very tough choice i mean
as you you've you've seen i mean there
are people like uh
you even have the
the original uzi in the book uh the man
called uzi that all uzis are
are named after what's his name his name
is
he lives in the united states he lives
in pennsylvania yeah
how did he get
no how did he get his name how did the
name the uzi gun and what was it what is
it
well it's um well i i i um i spent a lot
of time talking to oozy we both did but
um he explained to me actually i'm no
engineer
and he explained to me how
you know what his idea was
oozie is a guy who thinks about guns a
lot not in any kind of
how can i say
obsessive way
he's not interested in killing people i
mean uh i asked him at one point first
of all where did you find him
i found him he didn't really want to be
he lives in the united states he didn't
he asked me not to be too specific about
where he lives um
but it's on the east coast i found him
through other people who were interested
in um
had his shared his interests which is
you know the engineering of guns
i asked him in fact after the end of a
long conversation i said well you know
you're sort of intermittent about you
know uzis have sort of killed a lot of
people um i mean you know you're very
famous for what oozies do
to the human body
and he said yeah he said i read in the
paper about you know it's enter the
language people talk about oozing a
house so i expect him then to say you
know i'm sorry about that and he said he
said i don't deserve such fame he said i
just made a good gun so he's got pride
in his creation where was he when he
invented the uzi what is it for people
who've never seen a newsie well it's a
it's an automatic um it's basically a
submachine gun um it's small um it's
great virtues are that it's very stable
when you fire it it doesn't a lot of
these kind of guns you know they sort of
the recoil will pull it all over the
place
and because of some design features he
thought of
it's a very very stable gun i mean you
can hold it and pull the trigger and it
won't sort of jerk around it's also very
reliable won't jam it's easy to maintain
um
and you know the basic model he designed
in a british jail was where he had the
original idea he's uh he was living on a
kibbutz
um just when the british still
owned palestine
and the british came and raided the
place for arms of which they found a lot
and carted uzi off and he started to
have this idea about you know what a
really good gun would consist of and he
came out and uh
he actually sort of
started to work on the prototype in the
in this farm sort of the machine shop
where they repaired the tractors
um so it's you know it's become then it
was you know bought by the israeli army
and they decided to name it after him
the american secret service use it the
american secret service use it um
point out in the book i mean right here
in washington you've got the secret
service guarding the president at the
white house with uzis and a few blocks
down the street you've got the dope
dealers
you know guarding their patch and
eliminating rivals with oozies so it's
this universal gun of choice how did you
two meet
we met in uh in london
years ago
uh we met at a at a
club called zanzibar actually in london
what were you doing
i was
at the time i was finishing graduate
school over there
at soaz which is the school of oriental
and african studies i was also had just
started working at nbc news
where's home originally san francisco
and what is your relationship
well uh we're married and we work
together we make films together for pbs
frontline and we write books together so
it's a very close relationship what
other books have you written
uh this is our first together but uh i
wrote a book called out of control which
was about um
the reagan administration activities in
central america it was about covert
operations down there and wrote a book
called the threat which was about the
soviet military
out of control had what impact on our
body politic well it was interesting
because i had actually
spent a long time covering central
america
the north operation for cbs news in new
york where i was working at the time
and i broke the story for cbs about the
north operation in
central america so then wrote a book
which was basically about our adventures
uh in finding out about this stuff in
honduras and uh washington bars and
restaurants in costa rica it got into
the seamier side of what was going on
down there with operations
where'd you get your original interest
in this kind of a story
well i think it it gelled for me when uh
years ago in london
uh there's a very famous arms dealer
called sam cummings
who uh did a lot of work for the cia
he's one of the biggest
private arms dealers in the world and
he fascinated me and what fascinated me
was his ability to go into a situation
and supply arms in little wars
and
he he had no problem at all with
supplying both sides and that kind of
mentality of the uh the arms dealer
coming in into a little war just got me
very fascinated with little wars i'd
also i'd lived in africa while i was at
yale um i'd spend a lot of time in the
third world even then can you go back to
your early childhood somewhere or your
high school or college years and point
to someone or some
a parent or somebody that said that gave
you the kind of
boost to get into this kind of work
i don't think so i think it was a series
of things i think living in africa when
i was a student was very helpful where'd
you live
i was living in a village in kenya up in
the mountains
a place where they never seen a white
woman before it was quite an interesting
experience why were you living there
um because i was very adventurous in
fact i mean i've done a lot of things
like this and um
you know
as well as covering central america i've
i covered the war in cambodia the the
this
recent situation um i went to saudi
arabia during the gulf war i was you
know in israel under this gods this is
what i like to do
what do you remember about meeting
leslie
well um
what were you doing i was uh
i was at this party sitting at the bar
but what i was working at uh sorry uh i
think a precise moment what year this
was 1976.
got that right
um uh what was i doing i was working for
a british um sort of investigative show
called world in action um
in britain
the networks they you know they have a
lot of documentaries on television and
it's much more routine thing
so we used to it was a weekly show and
we used to actually it was a wonderful
operation um it used to be sent off and
you could basically do almost what you
wanted i mean provided it was a good
story
i think at that time what was i working
on
i was working on a story about how the
the had there was a huge argument going
on then as i suppose now as to whether
you know nuclear power was safe
and there were these rumors i'd heard
that there'd been
a nuclear accident in the soviet union
and this is long before the days of
glasnost and so forth
that there'd been a nuclear accident in
the soviet union and that that was very
mysterious no one knew much about it but
something terrible was supposed to have
happened 20 years before
and i set out to dig into this and i
found actually it was the first sort of
contact i had with israel i found
someone in israel who was a witness to
this accident who'd somehow been allowed
to emigrate
and tracked him down and tracked other
people down
i just remember sort of happy time alive
because i met leslie and also was
working on this terrific story so where
were you from originally i was from
ireland i grew up in ireland my father's
scottish but uh where in ireland uh
county cork east cork and what was life
like growing up there and when did you
leave there
uh
life was interesting it was like uh
actually we didn't have the early years
we didn't have a car
or a telephone or a fridge so i grew up
we you know went everywhere by horse uh
i grew up in a sort of 19th century way
and there was no difference between the
way we were living and someone 100 years
before um communicated by telegrams
perfectly i can tell people who
under the age of 110 that it's a
perfectly viable way to live
i left there i guess when i was
17
and went to work in london went to
school where
i went to school
in the american sense i went to oxford
studied uh
studied is probably exaggerating it a
bit
was listed as studying history
back to the book um
what do you think of the israel what do
you think of israeli people
what you've learned over the years and
being close to them
well both of us love working in israel
um i started working in israel i've been
going back you know
every year for
not not every year but have made
numerous trips to israel since um 1980
1981
israelis are very interesting people
also i mean
fact is um israelis love to talk
and are very tend to be at least in the
in this business in the arms business
and in intelligence
fairly gregarious and also um
they
have a lot of feuds with each other uh
very strong personalities so it's i mean
it's a very interesting group of people
to uh to work with are they tough are
they effective uh do i like them
yes uh really i gotta say i do um
very tough
um have an engaging cynicism about them
um
i did how could you not like it for
instance we're talking this may sound
bizarre but for example
uh we were talking to an executive this
is some years back an executive of
israel aircraft industries which is the
huge israeli defense aerospace it's the
biggest business in israel in fact a
bigger single firm
and um this is a time when
it was in the early 80s
there'd been a big argument here in
washington because the united states had
wanted to sell f-15 fighters to saudi
arabia
and the israeli lobby here kicked up a
huge fuss saying you know you shouldn't
be selling these planes but if you must
you shouldn't sell them with you can't
sell them with the extra fuel tanks that
will enable them to reach israel and
bomb israel should the saudis get that
idea
so the carter administration had agreed
that you know the f-15s would not have
the extra fuel tanks
a few days few years later we're talking
to um
this gentleman from israel aircraft
industries did you remember those fuel
tanks that weren't allowed to go to
saudi arabia and we said yes and he said
do you remember how that ban got dropped
which had by that point and said yes he
said do you know where those fuel tanks
get made
he said where he said tel aviv we make
them
so i mean he was delighted he thought it
was a great joke and a great sort of you
know business coup
that his firm was making the fuel tanks
which would theoretically at least allow
saudi arabia to bomb israel
i mean for example you have things like
um
we got to know quite well uh a man who
we refer to in the book as the colonel
who is american intelligence official
working in israel spying on israel
spying on the israelis
and um of course the israelis knew he
was doing it he knew they knew he was
doing it
and when he got to the end of his term
in israel the chief of israeli military
intelligence threw him a big going away
party and said
we like you you're more israeli than the
israelis now get out of here and don't
come back
so it's a it's such an interesting
interplay between these people you tell
a story early in the book um
you know i've never heard anyone
pronounce his full name so i don't even
know if he's right james jesus angleton
or they call him jesus what what did he
ever he's always everyone
although it should be jesus because that
was in recognition of the mexican half
of his family
everyone always pronounced it jesus
you tell an early story about a monument
to him near yad vashem the memorial to
the holocaust explain that story right
well um
if you're going
in on the outskirts of jerusalem on the
western side at least you have yad
vashem which is the very moving memorial
to the holocaust
if you take the road past there out of
town you go down the hill and you wind
through a pretty village and eventually
come to the what's called the jerusalem
forest which is full of memorial groves
if you like to um
to people but you know get honored in
this way war heroes or simple people
have been killed in war people
recognized by the state of israel
and
we were driving through this one day and
the reason we were doing this was we
were looking for the memorial grove
memorial forest to james jesus angleton
because angleton was a cia man a senior
cia official very famous for a number of
reasons but he was of interest to us
because he was the link for many years
between the cia and the mossad
and the israelis had all said to us his
old intelligence friends had said oh yes
we love jim and jim was a good friend to
israel and we liked jim a lot and in
fact
when so you know after he died which is
in 1987 we erected a memorial you know
created a memorial forest for it and
it's out there and you know i suppose
it's a bit hard to find you might not
want to look for it but i can tell you
that it's there so we thought we're
going to take a look
so we drive out and all these nice grows
with nice plaques carved in stone to
various people and we can't find the
angle to memorial
and eventually
we decide to give up we think we've
taken we've
you know taken the wrong direction on
something so we're looking for a place
to turn and there's an open space so it
looks like an open space we drive up
but it isn't
let's see it's basically a garbage dump
with a few stunted dying little trees
poking up
and a plaque actually on plastic screwed
to the stone to james jesus angleton so
this was the memorial forest and we felt
it's kind of hard to explain but it's uh
in a way it was an israeli joke you know
it was um
look you know we're supposed to like you
a lot we're supposed to owe you a lot
but we don't owe anyone anything so
here's what we really think of you and
it's a garbage dump mr angleton is dead
he's dead but not forgotten
new book just out about him yeah but it
doesn't really go into the israeli side
which is what interests us i mean you
know he had angleton did a number of
things he was you know his best he's
been most written about
because he was head of cia counter
intelligence
and was searching for you know got
obsessed about a soviet mole in the cia
but
although that may be the most publicized
role he had he did other things too in
his most important job really and this
is the role that the agency has always
been very
keen to obscure
in fact they prevented
one former colleague of his in the
agency from writing a book about him
because they said ah my god if he writes
that book he'll talk about this
particular job which was angleton's role
as a liaison
with foreign intelligence services
including the israelis
particularly the israelis in fact
and this was an absolutely key role
there's a lot of bodies buried there
because if what angleton was able to do
if there was things the cia couldn't do
or didn't want to be seen doing or you
know want to do in this country which is
legally precluded from doing
angleton could go to his buddies as
liaison could go to his buddies in
foreign intelligence services and
particularly the israelis and say help
us out
and that you know that was angleton was
really the sort of point man for the
connection that we explained in the book
what would happen
if all american aid to israel was
stopped and the israelis had to shut
down their arms business what happened
to that country it would be a disaster
why because the arms business is the uh
is the engine that drives the economy of
israel
um you know it's the biggest export uh
it's they have to at this point it's
such a huge part of the economy that
they have to continue shipping arms
which is why one reason why you get a
situation where they're shipping all
over the world and particularly
um you know unattractive situations like
shipping to south africa
so uh it's it's all driven by money by
the desperate need to keep this uh
business going i mean people will say to
you well
we had to we had to uh go into the arms
business in a big way because we wanted
to become self-sufficient because of the
part there's always a possibility of a
next war but in fact what's happened
because they're very military aid
dependent on the us what's happened
is that
they're more and more dependent on
american components on american research
and development and uh
you know hardly self-sufficient
and also i mean there's another element
of that which is the they have this huge
arms industry that they have to keep
going and it's the major provider of
employment in the country
especially of well-paying jobs
their markets as sort of were as wars
sort of tailing off around the world
they see as their
principal
uh future growth market the pentagon
here
so they're becoming you know they're
becoming trying to be in fact more
dependent or getting more business
out of the us out of the us military
which certainly does you know doesn't
make them self-sufficient if your
economy depends on selling stuff to the
pentagon or
um tending that way you know then that
makes that connection even greater but
there's also on the intelligence side of
things um
when i say their need for for this
industry the military industry is
desperate
um you have a whole intelligence branch
that was set up called le cam to get
high-tech you know military technology
around the world by any means and that
includes stealing it so you've had a lot
of cases over the years of the cam
operations including in this country
going around to different companies and
getting a hold of the blueprints and
carting away boxes
to bring back to tel aviv because they
have to stay ahead of the curve do the
israelis lie to the public
well uh
you know there are a number of things in
talking about this kind of stuff covered
operations national security subjects um
there is censorship in israel so a lot
of these things can't even be discussed
i mean we talk about in the book the
israeli nuclear program and breaks some
ground on this you know we talk about
the israeli chain of command that it
takes the prime minister the
the
head of mossad and the defense minister
to to make the decision to push the
button to push the nuclear button
is this the nuclear facility at demona
that's correct is that the only nuclear
facility they have well it's a it's an
enormous nuclear facility i mean but
what we've discovered do you try to go
there i've been to demonia yes inside no
no no no no that's very difficult where
is it it's down in the negev it's out in
the middle of nowhere and what happens
is when you go to demona um if you
happen to stop the car and take a
picture of it or film it or whatever you
know you're you're out of there very
quickly one um defense intelligence
agency friend of ours said that he had
more flat tires in front of demona than
anywhere else in israel but uh but what
we also discovered was um that israel
not only has nuclear weapons but
sophisticated tactical nuclear weapons
just like we do remember
uh the army used to have the american
army used to have nuclear land mines for
example all over germany well the
israelis we've discovered have nuclear
land mines seated on the golan heights
and at one point ariel sharon who is
of course famous for the invasion of of
lebanon and whatnot
went to begin and said look you're busy
you know uh and and had a terrible
relationship at the time with the chief
of mossad he wanted to take over seoul
control of the nuclear button and began
fortunately said no
but this kind of thing i mean that's why
it's um
the israelis have gone wild for the book
and they they've uh serialized it in
mahrif and written about it in haaretz
because they
they can't talk about this sort of stuff
unless it's been printed abroad before
marie and haaretz are what
they're two very large israeli papers
haaretz is
the kind of new york times of israel and
mariv is the big conservative paper and
you point out in your book that one of
the things you did differently with this
book he's had a lot of translations of a
lot of hebrew and israeli newspapers why
because um there's a lot an amazing
amount of information that appears in in
hebrew
and the israelis feel comfortable about
this because if it's in hebrew it's like
it's among themselves
uh that doesn't get translated into
english i mean they're very conscious of
the feeling that hebrew is like a code i
mean not many people outside israel
actually speak it
so uh you know if you can say something
in hebrew it's almost like saying it in
secret
so we discovered that for instance the
hebrew press
um
in israel it's amazing it's a very very
good a lot of very good journalists
they're very good newspapers um an
amazing amount of information that never
finds its way into the dispatches of you
know correspondence of you know foreign
correspondents from israel very few of
whom actually speak hebrew
um
and he's certainly or nor does it appear
in the english language israeli papers
like the jerusalem post i mean someone
said to us um you know what the function
of the jerusalem post is and he said
what he said is to uh he says to give
the [ __ ] give the american ambassador a
happy breakfast
so if we uh so they're very conscious of
you know hebrews for us and english is
for everyone else um
we also found that you know books and
also so diaries documents there's also
treasure trove i mean that israelis of
course you know are good at keeping
secrets i mean a good you know it's not
like they spill everything out and they
have total freedom of information but
there is still a wealth of detail and
information and color and
a lot of what you need to know to
understand the connection we're talking
about in in hebrew how did you get it
translated when was it expensive
yeah but we thought it was you know it
was worth the investment can you give us
an example of something that you learned
that was in hebrew that we never saw in
english sure um the 67 war for example
um
the uh you know the general people's
general view of this 1967 war was all
the arabs sort of ganged up on israel
and maybe even attacked israel and the
israelis fought them off and won the
great victory which got them the west
bank that people are arguing about today
in fact um quick background i mean
according to
you know the
these well put it this way
we found um
a book of memoirs written by a guy who
was the
military aide to the then prime minister
of israel this guy called israel yo
and he gives an account in here in his
in this book which has never been
translated into english it's available
only in hebrew in fact wasn't even a
sort of bestseller there
he gives an account how on june the 3rd
1967 two days before the war broke out
he was
at the home of the prime minister and
they were waiting for the head of mossad
to come back from washington because the
head of mossad have been sent to
washington to get
permission to get the green light
to launch the war
and he explains you know we knew we
could win he's explained already in the
book he says we knew we could win the
generals were hot to go they weren't
really scared of the egyptians or anyone
else
but they wanted to go ahead with this
and the prime minister been saying no we
can't do it we can't attack until we
have american permission
and he gives this very vivid description
of how uh
mara meet the head of mossad comes back
into the room at midnight and they're
all it's the sort of high command that's
sitting around and this being an israeli
meeting the air is thick with cigarette
smoke and
and
a meat walks back in they say well what
is it you know is it war or no war will
they let us go and amit says well i've
been given to understand the americans
have told me that they would bless us if
we crushed nasa
so they said that's it
and they started the war on monday
morning and he'd been to washington and
he'd seen richard helms head of the cia
and a few very few other very senior
officials and also including certainly
james jesus angleton and they got
permission to do it so that was
something that never been in english
i mean it really you know once you've
read that you understand that things are
a bit different from the sort of kind of
histories you read in english where do
you two live now washington
and where do you two work besides doing
books like this now
well we have lead a busy life
we make programs for abc news
i made two programs big programs during
the gulf war for them
uh big hour on cambodia uh and together
we make films for pbs frontline and have
for for some years now but you operate
as outside consultants in this case or
outside producers not on the payroll
every day of these organizations oh
absolutely i was on the payroll of one
of the big networks for years cbs news
and found that if you're on the payroll
all the time then you can't do anything
else and because we like to go back and
forth between films and and books
uh also we like to go back and forth
between two different
you know pbs and abc or one of the
networks are quite different how do you
get coburn out of cockburn
it was some idea that happened back in
scotland um several hundred years ago
i'm not responsible but
but all coburns carry this mission
through life as your name is spelt
cockburn but you pronounce it coburn
and there are people who give up the
struggle and change the spelling to
c-o-b-u-r-m but we regard them as
backsliders who is alexander coburn he's
my brother who's older uh he is
and uh
do you have still have a relationship
with him and what's he do for a living
now we don't see him in the wall street
journal anymore uh no he's very nomadic
he um
basically alexander he's among his many
interests is collecting classic american
cars
now these i think now has 12 of them
distributed you know these are late fit
the big monsters in the late 50s and
early 60s and he hasn't distributed
around the united states so
he's basically he moves around the us in
a sort of great circle route um and he
has cars everywhere so he but he uh he
lives most of the time actually out west
incredibly busy and incredibly
productive i have a younger brother too
who
spent the war um the recent gulf war in
baghdad he's the correspondent he's a
middle east editor for an english
newspaper the independent and
your brother was very opinionated and
very very visible especially was in the
wall street journal does that give you a
problem that people automatically
ascribe
his views to you um
not sometimes i mean not really i mean
it's um
he often gets confused with me as well
so we've you know i just get used to it
um are you alexander no i'm andrew or
whatever and he also gets confused with
patrick of course who's um
most of the time in the middle east and
how about politics do either one of you
consider yourself strong political
people
i don't
did you get accused of that though
well look whenever you're looking into
this kind of stuff whenever you spend
your life you know collecting frequent
flyer miles to go to places like
cali colombia and dahran saudi arabia
and
thailand and you know when you're
actually going out and finding out stuff
the world doesn't fit into a neat little
package it's always a little different
from what people expect it to be so of
course you're always going to get um
it's always controversial the truth is
controversial
people have trouble such as making
leslie out we were talking to a
master israeli arms dealer
called shapiq shapiro who um
looks the part too he wears very
expensive dark glasses and silk shirts
and smacks big cigars and
seeing talking to him in his very
elegant office opposite the ministry of
defense in tel aviv and
leslie is explaining what she's been you
know he was we were talking like we're
talking now and as he was saying oh i've
done this and done that and
shaping took the cigar out of him and
said i see you're a spy
it's happened more than once
but there was another
again a master uh
israeli uh intelligence
operative who uh we were
in manhattan it was late at night we
were in a hotel room
grilling this guy for information and he
said he turned to us and he said your
shin bet which is you know domestic
israeli intelligence so
um it's as i say it's always more
confusing than it seems one other thing
another quick question how many times
have each of you been to israel
you list a whole bunch here like 81 82
83 84 like every year is that both of
you go you travel together sometimes
together sometimes separately
we've been for different things so we
did a big we did an hour for frontline
about three years ago yeah that where we
traveled several times together that was
four or five times for me at least
when they see you coming into the
country did they do anything special
like trail you
oh
no i feel very comfortable working there
i mean as i say i was there during the
the gulf war um
under the scuds and had absolutely no
problem at all in fact i broke the story
about the patriots misfiring uh it was
very interesting because you know in a
situation like that it's it's pretty
scary and most people whipped on their
gas mess and went into their sealed
rooms but of course you can't see
anything in a sealed room and there's no
telephone it's you know you're
completely in the dark you may as well
be in washington
so we set up on the 14th floor balcony
of the tel aviv hilton where we got a
brilliant view of what was going on and
then could rush down and you know go see
what the damage was
but one night uh four patriots there was
a battery very close to us a patriots
and the first one flew up and exploded
in midair the second two flew so low
over tel aviv that they were going under
some of the larger apartment blocks and
the fourth
took off went up and did a hairpin turn
and came down in front of us and i said
that's it i got on the phone to new york
and said this is really a very bad
situation because you know you the
population of tel aviv was suddenly in a
position of not only have scud having
scuds raining down on them but patriots
too
so um i was just saying a question of
being being trailed in israel um
israel's
if you're
if you're not palestinian at least um
it's quite an easy easy country to get
into
the the interior on the way out is when
they talk to you um at this you know as
in most airports they want to do a
security check and sort of see if you
haven't got a bomb in your baggage
but that they also they'll give you a
prolonged interrogation as to where
you've been want to see your hotel room
want to know who you've talked to i mean
it's um
and as as international flights tend to
leave israel at four o'clock in the
morning
i mean
so you've gotten up at two
or not gone to bed or
groggy and then sorry i decided to
remember sort of
you know the interrogators everyone
you've talked to in the last month is
can be quite a trying experience you
tell the story about a group from
philadelphia
the group of philadelphia jews i believe
making the pilgrimage to israel and then
you also at one point
talk about being one of you or the other
maybe both of you together were with uh
eric sharon
uh traveling near near the uh green line
of the west bank and
being able to
what i'm getting at here is there was
some cynicism coming through all this
about what the israelis do about
american jews coming to israel on the
pilgrimage who wants to tell that
well and the golan heights strip and and
rob mr rabin coming in with his
helicopter and landing and all that if i
remember it correctly yeah there is
cynicism
and it's very interesting because
frankly
you have a situation where american jews
come over
and they're donors
i mean i had the experience of being
with a group of very big donors
and
we went up to
a spot in the west bank overlooking
what's called the coastal plain
i was with ariel sharon
and he was making the point to them of
how dangerous it was to give up the west
bank because of course then you could
have
uh missiles flying in from jordan and
you know could hit tel aviv whatever
anyway so so he gave a very good
demonstration he had the charts everyone
was listening then they all got back up
on the bus
and he turned to me and he said don't
you love it here isn't it a beautiful
spot for a summer house
it you have to understand that i mean
obviously sharon takes security
seriously i mean this guy is a is a
general and has been involved in
numerous wars in israel however
um
he's israeli and uh there is a sense of
we're here and you're not you know you
live in new york or you live in
philadelphia we're here uh there's also
a very there's a there's a certain
snobism that we talk about as well um
there is a group in tel aviv who are
regarded as or they're called
wasps
um and what wasps mean it's not the same
connotation but but it's uh what um
white ashkenazi cybers with proteccia
which means that um you know you were
born in israel and you've got the right
connections you're from the ruling class
uh go back to the the group from
philadelphia
um
what is the tour when someone when an
american jew comes to israel
and they're donors where do they take
them
well um
there's
a number of set routes but the tour we
talk about here is a security tour where
they're taken to see like the one leslie
described you know
the spot on the green line where to show
um you know how vulnerable israel is
what is the green one the green line is
the old border with the west bank um
it's you know now it's
a national it's it's it's the border of
the
of the west bank from israel proper
so be taken to places like that to
masada maybe
masada is so it's a very interesting
place it's uh it's this fortress was a a
rock rising out of the desert
in the south and it's on the top of the
sort of ruins that have been excavated
in the last few years
it's where the last jewish um
rebels against the romans held out in 87
until in 1870
and the romans built these enormous
ramps to to you know
defend this amount of effort to get sort
of siege engines up this sheer rock to
uh to take the place and just before the
romans broke in they all committed
suicide so this is you know for very
recently it's a very sort of holy spot
to
for uh
for israelis um
mossada and to the golan heights for
example which again is very vivid to if
you want to sort of convey a sense of
israeli vulnerability you say when the
golan heights before 67 the syrians were
up here looking down on israel and they
could shell us and indeed did and you
know attack settlers and so forth
and we described in the book the um the
scene where the all these philadelphians
arrived
to uh
to witness an israeli army firepower
demonstration
and we really tell it through the eyes
of an israeli who was watching
it was a correspondent for haaretz big
paper
because he reacted to it he said this is
ludicrous how demeaning for us that we
have to put on this circus for all these
for these americans um who don't
understand us
and they uh
you know he he describes he basically
describes the israeli soldiers having to
perform like seals
just for the gratification of the
american donors in order to sort of wait
for the handout and he said it's very
demeaning for israelis to have to sort
of do this i mean it's very sort of
he right does the handout come
eventually no well yeah the handout the
overall handout of course for one reason
another is you know many billions of
dollars a year um and although the
private donations
aren't as as big as the
u.s taxpayer donations they're still
very large israel bonds or direct
contributions um
so that's something the israelis pay a
great deal of attention to who was was
it the former defense minister rabin
that came in the helicopter yes and at
this far
in the golan the um
in the middle of it all uh
uh there's an announcer it's like a
fairground there was an answer crackling
announcements in english and this was
supposed to be they were saying we're
showing you the israeli army in training
except all the signs were sort of in
english which would be odd since you
know israeli speak hebrew and all the
commands that were issued were in
english too which is again odd for a
real demonstration in the middle of all
this you know pattern in comes the
helicopter with issac rabin um
who makes us made a stirring speech and
everyone presented medals and awards to
each other and then the uh the idf the
israeli army went on to attack the quote
unquote syrians which was a pile of
barrels
and blew them all apart
guess the one i want to ask you is that
do you think that this group of leaders
meaning everybody in the intelligence
community in the military and in the
government
are sitting behind the scenes laughing
at the americans coming over giving the
money this is no that's much too strong
the the the reason why we put that
anecdote in the beginning of the book
about the demonstration that wasn't a
real demonstration
uh
was you know it that's one side of
israel but we immediately asked people
to take a tour down this street that
andrew mentioned before hamalek next to
the uh the ministry of defense um which
is the real
uh
the real israel for this security system
but they didn't take the philadelphians
down the street where the defense
ministry is located no and they're they
don't get to spend time with uh these
kinds of people absolutely why not
because this is a world first of all
because uh
you know if you if you're not in the
business in some way or a or you know
meddlesome journalists like us why go
there um
you know i mean they would have nothing
in common they would have nothing to
discuss these are very
tough seasoned operators we're talking
about here and they can't be bothered
with you know seeing a tour group unless
they happen to be a politician i asked
you earlier whether or not the israelis
lie about what they're doing and i want
to ask you the same question about the
american government you catch the
american government in a lie when you're
covering them about things like arms and
drugs oh sure i mean the uh the american
government um
that means a number of lies on the
record i mean it's continuing of
continuing embarrassment um
i mean the great one of the great lies
of the 80s was the for instance that we
weren't selling arms to iran
well we were we were doing it through
our israeli proxy in fact as we reveal
in the book um
the um we were doing it from day one of
the reg administration we have a
uh someone we spoke to actually on the
record general avraham tamir who was
like the sort of brent scowcroft sort of
shadowy back
backroom figure you know uh advisor high
level advisor to
these ready governments um through the
1980s
i mean he told us how al hay gave them
permission to
to sell arms to iran from day one of the
administration he also described to us
again a lie i mean the the was the lie
that uh that we weren't involved in
anyway in the israeli invasion of
lebanon
he described how
he and eric sharon came to washington in
the spring of 1982 to get the green
light to invade lebanon and you know he
lays it all out and he explains why
hague wanted them to do it and uh
he said he said hague sort of said
okay we want a minor operation and then
tamiya went like this he said it's a big
word minor i mean because they never did
this huge war american government lie
of course all the time um
i think
i mean you know we saw it in spades in
the 80s uh
particularly
what we know of now is iran contra but
interestingly enough uh in as part of
that on the central america side of
things for example
we were not given a very good picture of
what israel's involvement was in central
america during that war in fact what we
reveal in the book i mean not only did
you have the operation like tipped
kettle where william casey turned to the
israelis and said we want you know
hundreds of tons of weapons for the
contras which he did which they
delivered
you had israeli advisors running around
honduras as early as 1981. you had one
of the guys on the contra directorate
would go regularly brief the israeli
council in tugucigalpa in honduras about
how the war was going
in
panama uh
emanuel noriega i mean no one wants to
touch him anymore but he was certainly
great friends with uh people in the
white house and in the agency
uh in as part of the whole contra effort
and at his right hand
was my karari known as mad mike in
panama who was former chief of
clandestine operations for mossad for
israeli intelligence this is noriega's
business partner this was a guy who
imported half a billion dollars worth of
israeli arms into panama
and was intimately involved with the
secret side of the operations of
training uh and supplying the countries
that were coming out of panama where did
you get all the intricate knowledge that
you have of the mike harare
departure
from uh
panama on that night of the invasion
well that's interesting because that
comes from uh that's piece indeed you
know there were there were a few very
good journalists there at the time uh
americans
um the hebrew press has some excellent i
mean there are people over there who
really tried to track that down because
they were very interested to see my
karari suddenly back in tel aviv at a
time when the u.s military controlled
the ground the air all exit points this
guy suddenly disappears and also the
panamanians have come out you know the
guy who became the the chief of staff of
the panamanian military
said that the u.s officials told him to
stay away from hawaii not to ask
questions
just stay away from it you say he got
out in a c-130
well we don't know exactly how he got
out
we think he did yeah
who's who's c-130
well i think there's only one country
that has c-130s in the net that
neighborhood and that's the united
states but we don't actually know how he
left the country how he left panama but
he left
at a time when he shouldn't have been
able to get out where is he now
back in his house um i think well he's
still building his new house in tel aviv
right yes that's right um and he and my
karari
was involved originally in the olympic
massacre well he wasn't involved in the
massachusetts after right he was in
charge of a hit squad that was set up uh
by mossad to go around personally
ordered by the then israeli prime
minister golda meir
to go around uh
uh
assassinated killing
the you know the palestinians who've
been involved in the munich the massacre
at the munich olympics in 1972
and it all came to um they had some
success and then it all sort of crashed
to earth when they went off to norway he
and his team to um
to deal with a guy they was known as the
red prince a very sort of important
palestinian um
and uh they
there was their man and they got ready
and then they killed him and it turned
out to be a moroccan waiter it was just
uh when you find out things
that are new and different and revealing
about governments that lie do you get
mad or do you get excited when you find
it out and always what's what's your
personal reaction no i don't get mad i
get very excited
i got very excited while we were working
on this book when we got a hold of some
documents that uh a lot of fbi files and
others that had been secret uh which
were released under freedom of
information about the cover-up of a
series of white houses administrations
of uh israeli nuclear espionage in the
united states and sitting there pouring
over those documents
reading
accounts of white house meetings
reading memos from for example
when nixon came into the into office the
second thing he asked j edgar hoover to
do for him was get me the files on
israeli nuclear espionage and likewise
the johnson administration
when
cia director decalms briefed johnson on
what was going on with the israeli
nuclear program johnson said don't tell
anybody not even russk or mcnamara who
were of course
his two very senior people
um so that kind of you know being able
to find out getting a glimpse of what's
happening in the real world what's
happening on the inside is
right do you get mad or do you do you uh
get excited uh sometimes i must say the
sort of enormity of some some crime uh
takes my breath away and i
you know i think
yes i do get indignant sometimes but i
like leslie and i think like most
journalists uh you know i think when you
actually find out or figure out ah
that's what they were up to
that's um you know that it's a great
surge of excitement you get when you
have that feeling here's who the book is
dedicated to chloe and olivia
who is it
how old are they
seven and 12.
they typed that dedication themselves
they wanted to make sure it got in they
didn't trust us to do it so they went up
the typewriter and did how did you both
have time to have two children in the
middle of all this running around
well um when i was pregnant with the
first one i was let's see when i was
eight months pregnant i think i was
working in on a story in west africa at
the time in liberia
when i was pregnant with the second one
i was working in israel
i was working in various on various
stories so
just keep going
what's next
uh we're headed back to the middle east
uh not to israel um right now although
since the israelis are very interested
in the book we probably probably should
go there but
no we're going to the uh
um going to other countries in the
middle east we're working on another
frontline film
and do you want to write another book
oh sure
what if you had it if you could do it
today what would you write it about
i couldn't say i couldn't say i mean
there are ideas that are already
starting to to uh gel for us but we
won't do another one probably for
another year either of us i don't think
yeah it's pretty
writing a book is
an intense experience which don't repeat
too often here's what the book looks
like
it's called dangerous liaison the inside
story of the u.s israeli
covert relationship and our guests have
been co-authors andrew and leslie coburn
thank you both thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
join us next week on booknotes when our
guest will be author liva baker in her
book justice from beacon hill ms baker
examines the life and career of former
supreme court justice oliver wendell
holmes that's next sunday on book notes
at 8 and 11 p.m eastern time
for a transcript of tonight's program
send five dollars to c-span transcripts
in care of tape writer incorporated post
office box 885 in lincolnshire illinois
the zip code is six zero zero six nine
coming up next on c-span it's our weekly
program devoted to the people and
politics of great britain we take a look
back on british prime minister john
major's trip to the united states and
his meeting in kennebunkport maine with
president bush this week
recently c-span's viewer informed